if you had to win a game show to stay
alive which game show would you choose I
would choose Jeopardy because I think
that I would not lose Jeopardy I would
come in second for sure in Jeopardy see
that's a smart I would choose College
Jeopardy because they spoon feed it to
those Rich Kids Celebrity Jeopardy yes I
could dominate that half cocked on that
Everclear from previous
oh my God Celebrity Jeopardy is I mean I
know we don't use certain words anymore
but the ones we used to describe the
level of question in Celebrity Jeopardy
because those are just embarrassing oh
yeah I would crush Liberty Jeopardy you
give me Demi Lovato you give me Pete
Davidson and me
they're going into the grinder